dans le port de pozzalo un cimetière de
bateaux des dizaines de coqs éventré
saisis par les autorités scène
d'embarcations de fortune
empruntée par des migrants désespérés à
leur bord des gilets de sauvetage des
effets personnels abandonnés témoignage
silencieux des tragédies qui se déroule
chaque jour en mer méditerranée car les
victimes de ces naufrages laissent pas
de traces à peine quelques fosses
communes à travers la sicile comme ici à
catane pas de pierres tombales
seuls quelques écriteau avec des numéros
parfois précédé de la mention cadavres
inconnu
mamadou bah il vient parfois se
recueillir ce guinéen est arrivée en
sicile à l'automne 2016
au terme d'une traversée dramatique je
vous jure le bateau s'est cassé en deux
là on parle là plus d'une noyade
on parlait de morts
moi je me suis noyée ne sais pas comment
je me suis sauvée j'avais perdu ma foi
si je n'avais plus folles je pensais que
j'allais mourir
les images de ce naufrage et surtout le
souvenir des disparus continuent de la
hanter
chaque jour chaque nuit d'avant une
femme qui était avec son bébé la moment
n'est pas arrivé le mieux n'est pas
arrivé sont des ménages super page pour
ne pas oublier ces victimes n'ont jamais
été identifiés
leurs corps jamais repêché mamadou
pleure aussi la mort de son meilleur ami
aboubakar il avait pris la mer quelques
jours avant lui il n'est jamais arrivé
simple dur de ne pas savoir là où le
corps de votre fils de votre ami
d'autres frais de watts heure et j'ai
juste envie de prier pour lui
[Applaudissements]
s'il est très courant pour ne pas dire
presque systématique l'anonymat des
victimes de la traversée n'en est pas
moins un outrage de plus pour ceux qui
ont tout risqué qui ont tout perdu
un outrage que certains essaient
aujourd'hui de réparer pour rendre à ses
victimes
un peu de dignité un peu d'humanité la
police scientifique de six ils traitent
chacun des naufrages comme une scène de
crime et recueils de plus d'éléments
possibles pour tenter d'identifier les
victimes empreintes digitales profil
génétique photos des corps et des effets
personnels
parfois nous retrouvons des objets comme
des papiers ou des téléphones mobiles
qui nous permettent de connaître
l'histoire derrière le corps dit il mais
la vérité et c'est que la très grande
majorité des gens repêchés ne sont
jamais identifié non porte
les victimes ont tout de même droit à
des funérailles musulmane et chrétienne
un drame auquel ne s'habitue pas l'imam
de catane c'est toujours il ya des mots
c'est toujours ya des gens qui arrivent
ces gens là sont victimes de
notre indifférence kate abdelhafid rêve
de pouvoir rassembler un jour tous les
migrants morts en mer dans ce même
cimetière
regardez chacun attend le maire de
catane lui a fait ériger un monument à
leur mémoire avec un poème en guise
d'épitaphe qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour dire que la ville de catania à une
sorte de attention humaines et
personnelles pour cette femme
et pour cet homme alors on a décidé de
faire une tombe
mais nous lui a choisi de rendre hommage
aux disparus en racontant leur histoire
en perpétuant leur mémoire pour
s'assurer qu'ils ne seront pas oubliés
on y quand tu quand tu affrontes un
combat avec des amis toi tu dois porter
la mémoire de ceux qui sont tombés 1
d'après les ong au moins 3000 migrants
sont morts en méditerranée au cours de
l'année qui vient de s'écouler